[Music]
foreign
[Music]
director for manufacturing and
Industrial Solutions at Google Cloud
hi I'm Simon Floyd and I'm industry
director for manufacturing and
transportation at Google Cloud welcome
to the smart Factory Transformers
in this new video series from Google
Cloud we tell the exciting stories of
how manufacturers are in the midst of a
transformation Journey digitizing
production processes and customer
experience using data and AI in this
episode we will talk about the art of
factory data analytics and visualization
so we have the packed agenda prepared
for you today from the business case to
to the technology walkthrough
Simon digitally enabled factories
generate enormous amount of data and
many manufacturers are aware of advances
in data analytics Ai and ml Technologies
so how can Google help manufacturers in
this area
uh great question suchitra uh we have
our data Cloud that provides data and AI
tools to all manufacturers that they can
use to take advantage of
um one example is that we provide time
series Data Insights in particular
anomaly detection for live or for
streaming data
and we have a range of machine learning
capabilities that can utilize
essentially any data set that a
manufacturer has
uh this is really very helpful for
manufacturers that wish to perform say
demand forecasting all the way through
to something very traditional like
predictive maintenance
it's also really worth highlighting that
we've invested in creating a solution
accelerator specifically for managing
manufacturing data at scale and
facilitating use cases that
manufacturers very commonly have so
manufacturing kpis and and so
uh and many of these can take advantage
of course of advanced analytics machine
learning and AI
that solution is called manufacturing
data engine
uh so suchitra before we dive into our
products and our Solutions uh question
for you how should manufacturers
identify where to start their Journey
a very relevant question Simon so as we
are working with many customers so I see
that scaling up digital transformation
is a little bit difficult but there are
companies who have identified their
Vision their goal as well as they have
identified the use cases across the
factories now for those companies as
they have identified the use cases and
the business value associated with them
they are actually able to reap the
benefits by increasing production
capacity uh reducing material losses uh
they are even improving their customer
service and delivery lead times and
reducing the environmental impact so I
feel a visual representation of
analytics use cases uh scaled across
factories can truly help companies
transform as well as you know they can
increase their competitive positions
um so Simon uh I know you have spent a
lot of time working with Ford and uh
their use cases uh especially related to
manufacturing data engine so can you
talk about the value we delivered to
food
yeah I'd be happy to do that and and
they say that
um time flies when you're having fun and
so it seems like it was such a short
period of time and and yet you're
absolutely true with actually as a
company and as Ford also invested um a
lot of time in this project and uh I'm
very happy to say that um uh you know
overall we got some some really great
results for Ford and uh actually we
learned to light ourselves in the
process which I think is really very
critical
so one thing I want to point out with is
that the success really goes to the the
credit of my colleagues and and also to
Ford for having the right level of
executive sponsorship to bring this
through and if even though we spent a
lot of time together working on this
um it was really time well worth
um you know all of us spending because
there was a couple of components to this
there was one component to it which was
just sort of the the understanding of
what we're going to be doing for the
organization and having everybody you
know buy into the vision and the
strategy effectively
um it wasn't just all about technical
deployment that there was much more to
this project
um much along the lines of what you just
mentioned as kind of best practices for
how people should really get started
um and we did something very very
similar um with Ford and so when we got
to the the technical deployment the the
part that's really great is that sort of
everybody was ready to go and all the
expectations were set on what we would
be able to accomplish as we go forward
um and and really that that mission if
you like that sort of overall Vision uh
was to provide new insights from the
data that they already have whether it
be historical information or whether it
be data that we'd be collecting sort of
live from their equipment on the factory
floor
um the reason why we we sort of built
this Vision in the first place is that
that really um you know as automotive
manufacturer that you know they're
obsessed with product quality and so
that that's one area that we thought we
could could contribute and then um of
course just overall you know efficiency
of their their production and
um you know all the way down to you know
kind of more asset management of the
equipment level and looking at health
uh we did find some interesting
um data points if you like or also
insights for the data points but
insights from the actual data itself
um we we really discovered that um
getting down to the the sensor level
that there were improvements that could
be made to the equipment
um very easily and before it was just
simply unknown even though that the data
was there uh it wasn't able to be
analyzed in a way that people could
action uh what they what they were
seeing and so we solved that kind of
core problem for them
the other part of this is that it then
gave us the right platform that we could
begin to predict what would happen in
the future with the machine and
something that I think is important to
note with any type of prediction is that
really this is a way of sort of
prioritizing your work so if you know
that the machine is going to behave in a
certain way going forward then then you
can prioritize resources if it needs to
be maintenance or you can prioritize
ramping up your production because
you've got certainty or at least some
confidence in how a machine is going to
perform going forward and then you know
we we expand that not just to kind of
machine level but in fact a kind of line
level and now we're really starting to
think much more at the production
efficiency level and then what does that
mean for um you know prioritizing
production of uh of certain parts or you
know assembly of the vehicle
so uh something else I think that is
perhaps worth kind of noting here is
that we did achieve a lot in a short
period of time when we had our first go
live in fact we were able to process 25
million records per week across 100
different machines and that was for two
factories that were geographically apart
from one another
and uh you know what this did is one
demonstrated that our solution
manufacturing data engine does really
help with scale in two ways one is that
it can be implemented very quickly and
it can it can give results very quickly
um which is important because what it
does is it puts together all of the
Google Cloud products that you need to
make this work and then unifies the data
across all the different machines
so now you have one way of analyzing the
uh the information across all the the uh
across all the lines and then across the
factories themselves
uh something else that I think is worth
noting there is that uh maybe not for
the first time oh that might be a little
bit of a difficult thing to say but but
definitely people notice that the
information was now a lot more usable
and valuable
um than what they were used to working
with and so in the past they would have
said oh the information you know the
first time was when we noticed you know
it was X but then you know things
happened over a wire time frame that got
us to kind of you know where we are
today which is is a little bit more
complicated because of the volume of
data and the proliferation of equipment
and so on so now we're having this this
you know second Epiphany if you like
that's catering to our current much more
complicated environment
um and and giving us the the
accessibility to the information in new
ways that uh you know was was not
possible uh before
now finally
um I think a couple of key points just
you know it's a great project a lot to
talk about it's a couple of key points
um one that I spoke to is just the ease
of use and so making it sort of one
system one data model really help people
uh in their own
um interpretation of the information for
their job and and that's really very
important they're going to take actions
they need to to back that up with an
analysis of the data so that they know
what to do and the second part actually
very simple is that when you have a more
traditional on-premise system expanding
storage can be um somewhat difficult
because you have to raise a purchase
order to get the equipment you have to
find time to install the equipment you
have to hope that you bought enough
storage and so on
um you know with our Cloud you don't
have to worry so much about that you can
just expand the amount of storage
um you know effectively in just a couple
of clips and then you get to where you
need to be and so that was incredibly
beneficial as well because it gave
forward the flexibility to say I wish to
store more or less information at any
one point time the workforce empowerment
piece I think is worth sort of re-noting
is that people really love this we've
got really great feedback and they said
this is kind of like an amazing
environment for us because there's all
these things that we can learn that will
help us in in our job that
um you know we're performing now and
feel great about it it wasn't just the
you know performance went up but
actually sort of the the overall
um you know mood went up amongst people
they just felt very positive about what
we were doing
um and then you know finally just from
an I.T point of view making this now um
self-service for people has just been
incredible productivity you know
increase for the organization in two
ways you know as it's not burdened with
trying to teach people a bunch of
different tools that they have to work
with and then trying to Wrangle uh
information stopping people from trying
to dump the data and go to a secondary
system and so on all of that uh you know
obviously now much much more simplified
and from the you know the the also from
an OT point of view from the operational
Tech point of view the people that
actually are in control and command of
those machines now have access to the
data as well that they can use as they
need
so that's it um so Chicho is a great
project and uh you know one that um
we're continuing to work on with Ford
and so very much looking forward to that
as well
so thank you Simon for sharing your
insights as uh as you know that as we
are working with other customers I think
customers are basically getting similar
kind of benefits I definitely feel that
the whole uh area about Workforce and
empowerment or whether it is about the
ease of use
um self-service Solutions these are very
very important aspects to our customers
so I'm really
um glad that you have shared these with
these benefits and summarize them well
so now we have a look at the demo
scenario based on manufacturing data
engine and looker from Google Cloud
hello everyone I'm Marcus and I'll be
your guide today
together we'll walk through some common
scenarios of using the manufacturing
data engine and looker from Google Cloud
using its Market leading Ai and data
products Google Cloud created an
end-to-end solution for processing
contextualizing and storing factory data
the solution leverages key Google Cloud
products including including Cloud
dataflow looker bigquery and Pub sub
for today's demo we've set up a
simulated Factory that generates
synthetic data and exposes it over OPC
UA interfaces
we've also deployed an instance of
Google's manufacturing data engine and
connected it to the simulated Factory
mte ingests harmonizes structures and
contextualizes the data from the factory
we have also set up an instance of
looker to visualize the data and enable
data exploration
using this foundational setup I will
demo two visualization scenarios one
real-time Factory visibility with a UI
ux optimized dashboards that allow the
simulated factory data to be visualized
as well as key kpis and insights to the
relevant user personas and second
integrated analytics that showcases how
easy it is to detect events in looker
the demo scenario is based on a
hypothetical company named motion PCB
Limited this company is a leading
manufacturer of rugged High reliability
printed circuit boards you can see one
of them at the top left motion pcbs
customers are mostly Automotive
suppliers who integrate their therefore
quality longevity and overall ruggedness
of the pcbs are key selling points for a
company
motion PCB decided to embark on a
connected Factory journey to improve its
efficiency increase quality and
consistency
the company has three goals in the first
phase one it wants to ingest live
factory data two surface this data in
views and dashboards optimized for
various user personas and three analyze
events and Trends in that data
motion PCB starts the smart Factory
implementation with one of their main
assembly lines this assembly line has
three machines one the stencil printer
starts within an empty Circuit with an
empty Circuit Board it deposits solder
paste with high Precision to prepare
electric joints for when the electric
components are added later
two the placement machine then adds
those components such as ICS commonly
referred to as chips the machine places
these directly onto the solder points
where the stencil printer already
deposited to solder paste before at this
stage the soldier paste is still liquid
and the components are not yet fixed
in the last step the Reflow oven exposes
the circuit board to a controlled
profile of heat which solidifies the
solder paste and creates a permanent
electric joint
at the end of the assembly line motion
PCB has installed a visual inspection
inspection quality control station this
station leverages Google's Coral TPU
modules to accelerate ml inferencing
this station was installed only a few
months ago
in this demo we have two personas with
different objectives
Carlos is motion pcb's Factory manager
he is looking for a clear understanding
of the factory status and seeing key
information at a glance
Carla started the connectors Factory
initiative and led the installation of
the visual inspection station
after discovering that quality
fluctuates he now doubled down on
connecting the rest of the factory to
see where those quality fluctuations are
coming from
Fatima is the maintenance engineer
responsible for keeping the assembly
line running she needs a more detailed
view of each machine and once to find
the root cause of problems to identify
the right fix
to help Carlos and Fatima do their job
motion PCB implemented a dashboard for
each of them
to show just the right information
let's start with Carlos the factory
manager
what you see here is the factory manager
dashboard that gives Carlos a high level
overview of his assembly line
in the upper part you'll see key
manufacturing kpis such as overall
equipment Effectiveness availability
yield quality and performance
the top right corner Services alerts to
make sure that Carlos's attention is
pointed to developing events early on
in the lower part of the dashboard
you'll see a visual representation of
the factory line along with Machine
level kpis
at the very bottom we surface quality
and performance As Time series data this
helps Carlos examine Trends very easily
currently the factories operating
normally producing pcbs at its expected
rate with average quality
besides the factory manager Carlos
there's Fatima the maintenance engineer
Fatima needs to have a more detailed
view of the factory to understand not
only if there are problems but also
where exactly they are coming from and
what root causes are driving them
to this end Fatima set up her own
dashboards without needing to write code
as our solution leverages looker Fatima
was able to configure the dashboard
simply using drag and drop
Fatima set up four dashboards for
herself the one here which gives her an
overview of the assembly line and three
detailed Machine level views
for example this style over here shows
detailed quality scores assigned to each
PCB produced this data is coming
directly from the visual inspection
module set up at the end of the assembly
line and the system can detect the work
quality of each of the three process
steps next let's navigate to The Machine
use and start with a stencil printer
Fatima set up this page to give her key
information about the stencil printer at
the top she has the stencil printer's
key kpis
in the middle section Fatima picked a
Time series View for the printer's three
sensors temperature humidity and paste
flow rate
in our example these are the three most
relevant process parameters that
determine the quality of this process
step
finally in the equipment log you'll see
key log entries coming from this tensor
printer The Machine's messages are
arriving in an industry standard format
with a number of different types of
messages info messages include for
example order execution for which the
machine simply reports starting and
finishing work on a PCB unit in the log
here you see these arriving in real time
now let's see what happens if the
stencil printer experiences a failure to
do this I will open the simulator UI
switch on the first event and collapse
it back
let's also set the view to show the last
10 minutes only to zoom in on the most
recent developments
once done the dashboard refreshes and
then shows the data
okay now we notice a couple of things
first the flow rate is deteriorating
that's interesting
let's see if the machine reports any
relevant status messages by looking into
the event log below
here we notice that the low-level
process control system in the machine
detected that the flow rate is
abnormally low good to know
notice that Fatima doesn't have a Time
series dashboard set up for quality
versus flow rate however she's like to
understand if the lower flow rate is a
cause for concern in terms of quality
this is where looker comes in it allows
Fatima to ask follow-up questions and
answer them herself very easily without
having to involve a data analyst a
programmer or anyone else for that
matter
to explore the relationship between
quality and flow rate Fatima simply
clicks explore from here from the flow
rate tile this brings uplooker's
integrated explore view that allows her
to investigate any data
what you see here is a chart with the
average flow rate over time and a table
with the data below
let's add quality to it in the sidebar I
simply search for quality and click to
add it to the chart
last I click run to ask clicker to pull
the data from bigquery
as a result I see both flow rate and
quality in the same chart and really
there seems to be a strong correlation
quality has been stable but deteriorated
quickly after the flow rate went down
this puts Fatima on the right track in
her maintenance investigation
Fatima investigates the stencil printer
logs and determines that the stencil
printing head needs a replacement she
replaces the printing head and will
reflect that by switching off the
simulated event
returning to the office Fatima checks to
verify that the quality scores are
returning to normal
however as in any Factory there is
always something going on in motion
pcb's assembly line let's see what
happens when we switch on the second
event
okay so now we see an alert in the
dashboard something is wrong with the
placement machine so let's dig in I'll
first open the placement machine
dashboard
foreign
here we have an overview of key sensor
time series for the placement machine
One sensor measures the acceleration of
the placement mechanics as it moves
across the circuit boards to place the
chips
the other sensor on the right measures
background vibration as the machine is
highly sensitive to any excess
background vibration
we see that the background vibration has
been pretty high for the last few
minutes acceleration also looks a bit
unusual exceeding normal levels
the log also shows several event
messages produced by the machine which
state that it has trouble stabilizing
the placement mechanics Fatima heads out
to the factory floor arriving at the
placement machine she opens the
maintenance view for this alert but this
particular error hasn't been detected
before and their root cause is unclear
after some digging she notices that the
power unit of the machine is excessively
loud and creates a strong background hum
luckily chanels had repair the power
unit and does it on the spot
to reflect that let's switch off the
simulated event
foreign
s we observe the vibration values
returning to normal
Fatima has done a great job repairing
the equipment
now back to Carlos in the office
Carlos is wondering if he can do
something about the oee numbers which
have some room for improvement
looking at the Quality scores for each
machine it becomes pretty clear that the
quality produced by the Reflow oven is
quite low this looks like a promising
opportunity to dig deeper Carlos asks
Fatima to investigate
let's look at the Reflow oven dashboard
to see if we can find anything that
could explain the problem
the machine reports no errors the lock
looks clean
so nothing obvious here
let's look at the sensor values if we
can see something
in PCB manufacturing the Reflow oven
needs to expose each circuit board to a
specific temperature curve to harden the
solder paste the only thing that stands
out here is that the peak temperatures
seem to vary slightly in their heights
housing over the chart it's clear some
Peaks are at 230 degrees Celsius some at
250 degrees Celsius but does this affect
quality and if yes which of the
temperatures produce better quality
let's go into explore mode to
investigate
first I will customize the chart to
focus on the most relevant information
to this end I'll remove the humidity
data series from the chart and I will
also set the time filter to the last 20
minutes
next I will add the average quality data
series to the report and click on run to
fetch the data
looking at this it's pretty obvious
higher Peak temperatures result in
better quality
seems like the Reflow oven is not able
to consistently create the right
temperature pattern
cytoma decides to involve the machine
OEM in this looker makes it easy to
share this view right from the screen by
clicking on the menu button then on send
I can share the report in various data
formats and over various channels for
example email let's send this to the
supplier and add a note
this helps shorten time to repair
sometimes dramatically by using data to
detect root causes quickly and remotely
in our scenario the supplier knows of a
bug in the oven control unit firmware
that can cause temperature patterns to
fluctuate the oven OEM rolls out an
update over the air to address the issue
to reflect that let's modify our
simulator
to see if quality improved Fatima
filters for the last 10 minutes and
refreshes the data and the quality
improvement is clearly visible this will
also drive up oee and Achieve Carlos's
objectives
well that's it for today's demo I hope
it gave you a good overview of the
virtually Limitless possibilities that
we can help unlock for our customers
thank you Marcus what a great session
now let's talk about scaling this
technology across factories and
Enterprises hi I'm Samuel Singh I lead
the global manufacturing practice at
quantify
let me take you through the typical
Journey for such programs from the pilot
phase to a large multi-line and
multi-plan scaling
the program normally encompasses three
steps
namely Discovery pilot and Rapid scalar
in the discovery phase which is spread
across two to four weeks interactions
are held with a cross-function team from
the client
then two representatives from Seniors
business leadership plant operations and
ID
the purpose of these interactions is to
hand hold the client to zero down on the
key challenges and identify a
corresponding Solutions shortland
a joint implementation plan for this
program along with the key client
resources time requirements it
prerequisites like network security and
data availability and dependencies are
called out to ensure a successful and
seamless pilot in the next phase
key metrics for success and the
calculation methodology is also
stipulated here
based on the above the ideal line for
pilot implementation is identified and
the downstream use case is associated
with the data being gathered are defined
it could be predictor maintenance inline
product quality throughput or yield
maximization root cause of failure
analysis oee optimization and so on
in the pilot phase which can be anywhere
from 8 to 12 weeks the first step is to
implement the connectivity between plant
equipment and the cloud
the ID team plays the pivotal role of
ensuring the right Hardware network
connectivity and security foundations
are set up
next with the plan instrumentation and
controls team the equipment tags are
mapped and then configured in the cloud
to enrich and contextualize the data to
Industry standards
post this the data begins to flow into
the cloud
it is now available in the unified data
warehouse ready to be validated for
Downstream Ai and ml use cases and for
visualization purposes
the pertinent AIML models are then
developed and deployed
the results and learnings from this are
assessed and shared with the client
leadership for further scalar planning
the subsequent scalar plan which can be
anywhere from two to four months is
classified into two phases
horizontal deployment across other Lines
within the same plant
and second the rapid deployment across
other plant locations within the client
organization
the first step ensures that the program
team understands the nuances associated
with scaling up and identifies any
possible hurdles or challenges
and iterative wave by wave deployment
model is used to optimize approach and
evolve the plan for Rapid deployment
across other plants within the
organization
during the second step the solution
are deployed across multiple plant
locations simultaneously leading to
significant time and Commercial
efficiencies
some of the key benefits of using this
approach for scaling include a unified
data warehouse with seamless data
ingestion contextualization processing
and democratization
user role-based visualizations give
visibility and insights across
operations
as a packet solution for end-to-end data
pipeline mde reduces time to develop and
deploy AIML driven use cases like
predictive maintenance visual inspection
and many more
organization-wide rapid deployment
bringing down implementation timelines
from years to just a few months
enhanced dealer governance and security
policies as out of the box features of
the solution
all of this at optimized costs and hence
the client derives maximum value
back to you Simon and suchitra
thank you Samuel for the great insights
and for being a great partner
just to recap today we walked you
through a couple of use cases and
scenarios in particular role-based
visualization tools and scenarios ease
of use of tools and services
democratization of tools through low or
no code environments and self-service
Solutions in other words minimum need to
engage i.t4 deployment of solutions
so suchitra this wraps up I believe uh
our session today
before we go what are the top five
reasons a manufacturer works with Google
Cloud
great question Simon so here is how I
would summarize
accelerated data transformation
we provide industry leading machine
connectivity through more than 250 ready
to use Machine level protocols
now secondly quick Twain set up through
automated deployment of a ready-to-use
setup on Google cloud and an auto
configured Ed stack
um accessible data analytics insights
and easy to use AI which is putting the
best of Google's data analytics
artificial intelligence to work into
industrial environment that is another
reason why manufacturers would choose
Google cloud and Manufacturing data
engine
and fourthly I would say advancing the
shop floor work for Force transformation
there is a labor shortage and I think it
is very very important that as
manufacturers automate some of their
processes it's going to be easier for
them to basically
um you know decrease that labor and the
skill scan and last but not least we
provide an integrated digital twin
engine for asset hierarchy and models
and integration with our supply chain
twin and optional integration to
third-party digital twin providers so I
hope you found the information we shared
today to be helpful uh reach out and we
will welcome you on this journey thank
you for watching this episode
[Music]